et parmi les événements
cinématographiques de la rentrée de
septembre nous pourrons voir un film
policier d'une série noire
réalisé par claude miller garde à vue le
tournage se termine avec 3 venette romy
schneider lino ventura michel serrault
michel drucker est allé assister au
tournage à versailles il a observé
comment deux monstres sacrés qui ne
s'étaient jamais rencontrés qui n'avait
jamais tourné ensemble ventura et sirops
rivalisaient sur un plateau pour donner
le meilleur d'eux mêmes ce héros drucker
ventura ensemble c'est l'arrivée
discrète plutôt plutôt des cibles
préférées autre chose ou à une arrivée
d'acteurs l'avoir faudrait un acteur
à l'arrivée d'acteurs forfait à bombay
vous voulez oui une deuxième
ce mental et vous bien on vous a pas
prévenu on est venu comme ça à
l'improviste
oui donc j'ai bien fait oui big z dans
votre loge peu mais oui pardon je ne
dérange pas selon lui sont faites comme
vous voulez oui ma compagnie oui ça vous
dérange pas un produit
entrez donc les mon cher ami entrez donc
on a deux acteurs d'égal force d'aller
dire est ce qu on s'observe est ce qu
ont certains avancent d'abord par
exemple une ouverture en hausse
connaissais pas bien c'est pour ça j'ai
jamais joué avec lui je dirais je le
connais pas très bien dans la vie je ne
connais pas très bien non je connaissais
pas maintenant je crains qu'on se
connaît un petit peu mieux mais oui on
s'observe
mais alors là on a eu de la chance parce
qu'on s'est observé je veux dire c'était
chronologique est arrivé j'arrive dans
son bureau une pose des questions et
joue l'inspecteur voilà suspect gère que
le fait parce connais très bien je pense
qu'un acteur doit se servir de tout
n'est ce pas ce qu'il a sous le souffle
sous la main c'était pour moi c'était
une condition qui dans ce film était
formidable parce que je sais est
observée mais je veux dire ça pouvait
très bien fonctionné avec un film on
était dans la situation de deux
messieurs qu'ils connaissent pas
tellement j'aime bien jouer ce que je
dis toujours c'est que ce qui m'amuse
c'est pas moi c'est pas ventura c'est
par jean s'est pas au noir et quand j'ai
tourné avec lui c'est pas ça qui m'amuse
sur son rival faut être deux oui non
seulement il faut deux mais ce qui est
formidable c'est ce qui se passe entre
jean et moi entre noirs et mois contre
aventure est moi c'est ce qui se passe
au milieu
n'est ce pas et c'est ça qui ferme en
avril la comédie c'est ce qui va se
créer à ce moment là donc si on veut
tirer la couverture ou vêtements ou sept
points intéressants puis je dire ils ont
fait ça dans un plan on peut pas faire
chaque compte
nuitée dans une histoire je viens sera
c'est pas le plus qu'aux médias un peu
dépassé le veer ça dominique tu fais
virer les tuyaux là s'il te plaît à
janot et
les attend
bien fêter l'été dans la rue mais on va
arroser moment tourner mathon
ouais ouais j'ai compris
le fait est que non jamais tournée du
chef michel ski
ce qui pour moi une découverte aux
sections de cajou à le dire
c'est ce que j'appelle - l'acteur vous
êtes tout à fait différente complètement
l'opposé à complètement
et puis robin est-ce que vous avez
l'impression de progresser toujours ça
oui sincèrement
oui
pas du tout
numéro chance
vrai
très sincèrement je vous réponds oui
votre ami gammon il est toujours en
parlant du cinéma cinéma c'est un peu
vrai l'histoire deuxièmement une
histoire franchement une bonne histoire
ça jamais été aussi vrai mais les bonnes
histoires seront plus en plus rares
alors c'est pour ça alors écoutez quand
vous dites que c'est fallait trouver
d'abord s'il y en avait de très très
bonnes je serai sans doute moins
pointilleux
et c'est sans doute un luxe
je
pas plus qu'ils n'ont pas fait
parmi eux
code va bien pour moi on se ressemble à
une dernière garde à vue de claude
miller pour le mois de septembre l'un
des événements de la rentrée
cinématographique dont nous reparlerons
bien sûr avec notre ami michel